okay welcome to another episode of
science and technology q a for kids
and others i think we had a few
questions left over but i'm
hoping that we can source
some new ones here
the questions here about mathematical
objects
and artifacts here i don't know what all
these artifacts are these are artifacts
from my i've collected artifacts of all
kinds so
maybe maybe another time we'll we'll do
a a tour of artifacts i don't think i'm
set up to do that right now today i seem
to have um
uh well let's see i mean i have things
like
this guy how about this there's an
artifact
okay why is this artifact interesting
this is a um
a mollusk shell as you can see and um
one of the things the reason i have this
is because i've made quite a study of
the
of the patterns that exist on mollusk
shells um
and uh the way a mollusk grows you know
when
when the when the critter is uh alive
there's a great big creature a soft
creature
inside here and uh what's happening is
at this it has sort of a lip on the on
top of the shell
and that lip is is excreting material
that forms the shell it's kind of like
like we um
uh like our uh hair cells gradually
produce
um uh uh hair that that some that
then exists as a sort of uh a separate
thing that doesn't have to be
alive itself and the shell the shell
itself is not alive it's only the
creature inside it that's alive
so these shells um they they gradually
they they produce some they grow
by by just growing out from the lip and
what happens is they eventually grow in
a spiral and i might even have them
see if i have at hand here i might have
a
sample of let me see if i can
reach back and find a sample of
something let's see
oh look at that i really do yeah there
we go i happen to have a sample
that's a shell that's been sliced in
half this is a nautilus shell
and what you see happening is it forms a
um
uh you can kind of see how it grows
because it's forming these compartments
i think it forms one of those
compartments essentially every lunar
month
um these these creatures are they have a
very sedate lifestyle
um but uh essentially but the main thing
one seeing is
when when the when the creature is young
it's very small and it's just
started at the center here and gradually
as it grows as the creature inside grows
it um is uh it's getting bigger and
bigger and it's secreting bigger and
bigger pieces of shell
um and that's how the shell forms and
this creature it's kind of like
different different kinds of organisms
have different schemes for growing so
mollusks
are growing this hard shell and they
grow
in a spiral like this plants for example
which have uh um uh
um they have the uh sort of
cellulose cell walls that are hard
plants uh grow by the they'll grow a
trunk
and then they'll grow branches and
they'll grow branches to the branches
and so on that's the sort of basic idea
for growing
um animals have sort of a different idea
well the the lower animals will have
exoskeletons they'll
they'll grow on the they'll they'll grow
inside then the skeleton they'll get too
big for the skeleton they'll shed that
skeleton
they'll form another skeleton and so on
we have skeleton inside
and as we grow uh sort of the the tissue
parts of us
are soft the bones grow they typically
grow from growth plates at the ends of
the bones
and we kind of kind of grow grow that
way so these different different kinds
of
organisms have different schemes for
growing molasses have a scheme for
growing that is
is this kind of spiral scheme for
growing and um
turns out different molluscs different
species of mollusks
basically just have different rates at
which
the spiral grows out versus the spiral
getting bigger
the rates at which the the the um uh
angles at which the kind of the the
mouth
of the shell um is oriented relative to
the direction of growth and so on
and just turns out it's about three
different parameters three different
um uh sort of things you can change
about the way the growth works
and all the different molos shells that
you see pretty much
come out the ones that are very flat and
form bivalves for example the ones that
are very
pointy and so on all those different uh
types of mollusks
seem to be pretty much using one idea
and they've just
changed a bit the rate at which this
thing grows versus that thing
this this aspect of growth versus that
aspect of growth
but um on the surface of these shells uh
there is a um a layer that their pigment
patterns
nobody really knows exactly what those
pigment patterns are for
you know it's a very common thing in
biology people say you know they see
some
feature of some organism and they say
that must be for such and such
and then they say the organism uh
evolved
to have a beak that was that shape so it
could
uh peck out these things inside tree
trunks or something like this
and sometimes that's a correct
explanation and you can kind of see how
you can tell a sort of backwards story
from what you observe the organism doing
to saying
yes that was a thing that it evolved to
do well etc etc etc
um sometimes it's a little bit more
questionable
that you can explain things that way and
i think what's really true is that
that what happens in the actual forms of
organisms is sort of a mixture
of things that can be explained in that
kind of backward way it is that way
because the environment
makes it more successful if it has that
feature
versus it's uh it is that way because
that's the convenient way for the
organism to grow that's the way that
um uh you can you can sort of have have
like for a mollusk shell you know that
they'll tend to have these spiral
patterns just because that's a scheme
for growth and everything is going to be
using that spiral pattern idea
and you might have variance on it but
everything's going to use that same idea
in terms of the the patterns on shells
it's much less clear what some of those
are for
whether they're for a purpose that can
be identified
or whether they are just sort of side
effects of the growth processes of the
organism
um the uh you know sometimes you might
think oh
it's got this weird complicated pattern
just like zebras have a complicated you
know pattern of stripes or something on
them or
a butterfly wing has a pattern on it um
you know
why maybe these mollusks are doing
something similar
not clear why having these elaborate
sort of triangle patterns and so on
uh what feature that would uh what
advantage that would give the organism
and sometimes some of the theories that
people have had
about why those patterns might exist are
pretty wacky theories in my opinion
uh one of the most bizarre that i ever
heard about
was the theory that the pattern uh is
kind of
that the mollusk sort of during the day
it's out and about and it's it's sort of
it's it's it's extended beyond the lip
of the shell
and uh it goes and it's sort of adding
more shell and so on
and it's also putting out this pattern
but it's also in the sense reading the
pattern that was already there
through some kind of neural net that's
in the in the
in the edge of the of the organism
that's hanging out of the shell
and then at night it would retract and
then the next day it would come out
again
and it would kind of have a memory of
what the uh
kind of reading that sort of the braille
or something on the outside of the shell
that is the pattern
i'm trying to use that to line itself up
again i think it's a very wacky theory
it's it's very you know that seems to me
a very implausible theory
the other thing that that's the case is
that some of these mollusks
have patterns that really aren't visible
until the organism has died
and um it's uh and the and the soft
tissue has been
uh sort of eroded away by the ocean and
so on
and in a sense the only selection effect
is for shell collectors so to speak
which means it's never going to have an
effect for the organism because
not the way natural selection works is
you get more of something because in a
population of organisms
because the organisms that have that
feature
like let's say let's say it's a really
good thing to be colored green
um uh because it gives you better
camouflage your predators don't
don't uh see you or whatever else and
let's say that
that uh at first birds of a certain kind
are randomly colored
well the ones that are red they're
predators
will say oh my gosh there's a red bird
go and eat it
um so that bird is then gone and it's
not gonna have
uh you know bird children so to speak on
the other hand the green bird
is uh uh might be that's camouflaged as
predators don't notice it so
it happily grows up and has lots of
children and
it will tend to pass that trait of being
green to its children
and so after a few generations it will
tend to be the case
that uh all the birds of that species
are green or many of the birds of that
species are green because
the red ones didn't have many children
or didn't have any children at all
and the green ones had lots of children
and that gradually that's that's the way
that natural selection
works um but so if
if there is a trait that doesn't affect
the reproduction of the species it's not
clear how that has a consequence
so for example in the case of let's say
it was the case that
yes the the shell collectors were very
excited about picking up the shells on
the beach
doesn't have any effect on the on the um
uh
on the organism directly perhaps it has
in the modern world a slight effect
because
it's often said that animals that are
more uh interesting and elegant looking
tend to be uh people put more effort
into their conservation
as a matter of sort of human uh rules
and
and habitat um uh uh conservation of
things like this if
if it's a if it's a cool looking animal
people will really worry about it if
it's a koala that really looks
cool and cuddly um people are going to
worry more about
preserving its habitat than if it's this
ugly looking black beetle that has
oozing stuff coming out of it and so on
and that that's so that's a very weird
kind of selection effect on these
organisms
but you know for example for one of the
things that that's often mysterious
is um things like uh
lifespans of organisms and and how that
has an effect
on how natural selection operates on the
lifespans of organisms because
because by the time you had your
children so to speak you already
contributed
to the gene pool of the species and so
what happens after that
is kind of not uh you know is not going
to be selected for by ordinary natural
selection
with the exception of the fact that in a
sense if you have very very old members
of the species all hanging around
not doing any good and just taking up
resources it's actually probably better
for natural selection if they die off
it's better for the species if they die
off now you can say well the you know
the grand bird the grandparent bird and
so on
might be useful for teaching the new
birds or might be useful for some other
purpose
and it's often hard to trace through all
of those effects
um but uh uh you know those are some
features of kind of the the world of
natural selection
let's see um you can talk some more
about biology i'd be happy to do that
um that was a question from mitchell
does the does the
pattern of shell formation have a
mathematical scheme so i've studied this
quite a bit
and the the actual shapes of shells
are well described by uh field of
mathematics differential geometry
they're
actually a fantastic example of
differential geometry it was all worked
out by um a chap um
oh what was his name reverend somebody
or other um
in the 1830s did a really good job of
working out
uh the kind of calculus mathematics
calculus based mathematics
of shell shapes and it's one of the
better examples so that you don't find
it in any of the
calculus books it's a little bit
complicated but but it's a it's a really
really good example of a place where
calculus goes in something in the in the
world comes out and it actually works
um uh and one of the things that wasn't
really known
was people thought that the range of
parameters that shells could use
to sort of grow themselves was a very
limited range that was a result of a
small mistake that was made by some
paleontologists in the 1950s and 1960s
which i guess i managed to to uh to to
fix
um in this big book of mine called new
kind of science
i have a little section about mass
growth um and uh when you when you fix
that little mistake
you discover that the mollusks of the
earth pretty much fill out the parameter
space
that is it's as if they just picked
their parameters for how the shell grows
at random
but then it turns out that the different
kinds of organisms the different kinds
of molasses
um you know the ones that are very long
and pointy they
make use of that long and pointiness to
wedge themselves in rocks the ones that
are very flat
do something different and so on they
make use of their different shapes
um and uh no doubt as they have lived in
an environment where they need to wedge
themselves in rocks they'll end up
picking
more and more and more of the ones that
are pointy and so on but but from a
mathematical point of view that's
actually pretty well understood that the
the shapes of molos shells are pretty
well understood in terms of the
pigmentation patterns i also worked on
that quite a bit
and these things called cellular
automata which are very minimal models
of programs
um very minimal kinds of programs where
you just have a line of black and white
cells and you just did each step pick
the new color of a particular cell
based on the neighboring colors of the
cells on the previous step
it turns out those very simple cellular
automaton rules do a fantastic job
of explaining the the kinds of patterns
that you get on mars
shells one of the things that's
surprising is some molasses shells are
very simple patterns
uh just stripes or spots and things and
others have these very complicated
they're often called diverica patterns
that are these elaborate kind of random
looking collections of triangles
one of the things that comes out of that
sort of simple computational model
is exactly those classes of of uh a
behavior it's kind of like who would
have expected
this complicated diverica pattern if you
see stripes and spots
you wouldn't expect that the other the
other thing that you shall see in
mollusks is a very elaborate thing with
a bunch of
weird sort of random triangle uh
triangles dotted around
and that's an interesting case of where
kind of the
the constraints on the growth of an
organism have an effect
on on what kinds of things can be
produced by the organism
and it's something where you know in
biology one of the things one can
think of is oh everything that happens
in biology is just the result of natural
selection
with a particular environment what's the
best way to do this etcetera etcetera
but i don't think that's really true
i think there's a big effect in many
cases from what's easy for the organism
to grow
so to speak and it's kind of like my my
version of this
is is the who expected the stegosaurus
question
so stegosaurus says i i always you know
one of the problems with dinosaurs is
you learn about dinosaurs many people
learn about dinosaurs when they're kids
and um the world of paleontology sort of
progressively moves on
and all the dinosaurs you thought you
learned about as a kid
they've all changed their names because
people realized they weren't quite
correctly classified
and they you know it's now so i don't
even know what the stegosauruses are
still talked about but they're the
they're the dinosaurs that existed
they're fairly early dinosaurs as i
recall
they have a big long um uh they kind of
look
uh they have they have lots of spines on
their back nobody
lots of plates weird shaped plates on
their back nobody completely knows
what those plates are for not clear they
were for armor it's not clear they were
one theory is that they were for
cooling of the stegosaurus that would it
would stand in the wind and the wind
would blow over these plates and it
would
sort of have uh blood going up into
these plates and that the the
sort of it would be for cooling the
stegosaurus i'm not sure if that's a
convincing
uh picture there are a lot of weird
theories about
about um how uh dinosaurs um
um why they you know why this why
question but there's also the question
of maybe
they exist in that form just because
whatever growth process
they have naturally produces that as one
of the possible outcomes
and if it's not terrible for the life of
the stegosaurus it's going to keep that
growth form
um and you you can see a lot of those
things even in humans there are things
that are like
we don't really it doesn't really seem
purposeful that we have you know
an appendix in our gut and things like
this but
yet it's kept because well that's what
evolution did it's not absolutely
disastrous
um you know and and so it doesn't it
doesn't get um it doesn't get modified
um but yes there's a there's a pretty
good theory for
for growth processes in general uh
mollusks pretty well under control
um i would say uh the growth of of
plants that are sort of tree-like
also that's one's pretty well understood
one that i've been interested in for
ages and ages is the growth of leaves
uh that's not very well understood
there's a huge diversity of different
shapes of leaves
and nobody really knows quite why they
exist that way why are there
you know maple leaves and oak leaves and
so on what are the particular
shapes what is the what is the purpose
of the particular shapes
yeah pretty much the only thing that's
that's known is that if you go to
tropical places rainforests things like
that tropical rainforests
you'll find a bunch of plants that have
these little little um
sort of pointy tips on their leaves and
those i think are usually called drip
tips
and you know there's a lot of rain comes
down and it sort of all collects and it
drips off that
that little tip at the end of the leaf
and that's that's one of the cases where
it's sort of
known what the point of some some shape
of a leaf is in other cases not really
known
uh i made some models ages ago to kind
of explain some of the diversity of leaf
leaf shapes um and uh but we don't
really know
uh what what is picking these different
leaf shapes or whether it's kind of
random
um and um uh it's kind of interesting
because the
you know the structure of leaves has a
very long history i mean people talk
about it and
you know theophrastus talked about it in
in in ancient greek times
and you know all these different shapes
of leaves you know there are the
lancelot lancel what is it called
lance shaped leaves there are the
dentate leaves that have sort of
teeth-like patterns around them
there are the there are all these
different typically latin names for all
these different
shape forms of leaves um and and this is
something that these shape forms have
been classified for a long time
but nobody knows why why leaves actually
work that way it's a it's an interesting
problem of growth there's you can look
at sort of um
growths of animals um
the uh um um
the thing that um uh uh you know i
always find it interesting to kind of
figure out
how did the animal grow you know you see
a shape how did it go what one that
had me confused for a long time is sea
urchins um because they they are this
sort of closed area that seems to be
quite hard
i think what actually happens there is
actually similar to what happens in in
human skulls
is there are growth plates there are
regions of the sea urchin
that are very hard but they have sort of
fuzzy borders between them and
the individual plates grow but they
still can be attached to other plates
the same thing happens in human skulls
which are grown in several different
parts um
and it's only i think the um finally
things sort of fused when people get to
their 30s or 40s
in in age and then then the plates
couldn't grow at that point but they
probably stopped growing long before
them but that's when the
the sort of the the the the what are
they called
the um uh the kind of suture lines and
the skull
finally close up um but
uh uh anyway so it's always an
interesting exercise to understand
things about how animals grow i
i uh i
know if you if you go i have to say i
used to say
years ago before i had studied uh growth
of organisms i used to say you know i'd
go to a zoo
and i i didn't really know what to look
for and i would be just kind of
looking at the expressions on the
animals and seeing if they reminded me
of people i knew and things like silly
things like that
and i realized there's actually a lot of
interesting stuff you walk around a zoo
and you look at these animals and and
you can kind of think about how did this
thing grow
and so for example let's say a good good
exercise is
um a leopard for example so leopard has
spots
and um if you look at the spots on
leopard you'll find the spots are bigger
and further apart on the main body of
the leopard
but they're much closer together on the
head of the leopard and the question is
why is that
well the answer is the original spot
pattern got laid down when the leopard
was a very small leopard fetus
when it was just just growing and turns
out that there's a process
in biology that uh is pretty good at
laying down
sort of patterns with a with a
separation where the separation of the
pattern is about 0.1 millimeters
so very very small separation between
the different parts of the pattern
and and that's a it's a process that
basically it's a diffusion of chemicals
it's a reaction diffusion process
that um uh where the chemicals are kind
of diffusing and reacting with each
other
and they will produce this kind of uh
consistent sort of wave pattern
of where um uh of of of uh
uh for example where there'll be pigment
and where there won't be pigment
um and so at when the when the um
when the leopard was you know uh very
small
that process took place and there was
sort of regularly spaced
uh thing which would become a pattern of
spots where the
distance between the spots was 0.1
millimeters well then the leopard grows
and it becomes a full-sized leopard and
so on um but
um uh what you realize is
that since the time when it was that
little tiny fetal leopard
the the head grew less than the body
grew and that's why the spots are closer
together on the head
further a part on the body because when
they were when it was a tiny little
micro leopard so to speak
they were equal distance apart on the
head and on the body but the body grew
more
when the leopard was you know uh was was
growing up so to speak
and so that's a you know it's just an
example of where you can kind of see the
um
uh the the how did it grow question and
it kind of tells you something another
another thing is pretty common is
animals that
are spotted on their bodies or striped
on their tails and those are basically
spots that sort of joined up around the
tail so to speak
and you see these kind of regular
arrangements of of like on the tail
you know you'd see a regular you know
black white black white
arrangement and so on and you can
understand that on the basis of this
kind of reaction diffusion process
that can happen i mean the the um uh the
the substance most often used in that is
is probably retinoic acid vitamin a um
that's a
and that's one of the things that that's
useful for if you're
a fetal mammal so to speak um
you need some vitamin a and that's one
of the things that gets used for
is is to help um is to provide this
so-called morphogen
that's used to to produce that that
pattern
i mean a thing that that's interesting
in the biology of this is
there is a sort of continuous diffusion
of the substance
and it kind of it just sort of it's a
smooth you know it's it's
bigger bigger concentration here smaller
concentration there and it's a smooth
gradual change
but then the whole operation of uh sort
of biological system
um particularly associated with these
things called hox genes they used to be
called homeobox genes they got shortened
to
hox genes um have the feature
that they uh involve a kind of a
biological processes that have a very on
off character so
even though the the concentration is
gradually changing over
over the region you know as you go down
the tail or something
there's gradually less and less and less
of this particular substance
but then it will turn out as a result of
these hox gene things that there will be
a discrete change
it's like you either get pigment or you
don't get pigment if the concentration
is
more than you know 0.3 or something you
get pigment
yep it's on if it's less than 0.3 boom
zero you don't get pigment
so it's kind of like what was an analog
kind of continuous system
is being chopped up into a digital
system um by
by that by that process see the same
kind of thing actually in plants
so one of the notable features of plants
is their so-called phylotaxis pattern
so if you look at a okay if you're in a
place where there are palm trees this is
particularly easy to see
if you look at it look at a palm tree so
palm trees
are the different the different schemes
plants use to grow i
keep on talking about the growth of
things that two principal
forms of plant growth the monocotylidons
and the dicotyledons
which pretty much have to do with
whether they have um uh sort of
i think that those names come from
whether they have one sprout when they
come out of the seed or two
but a palm tree has the feature that it
grows
there's only one place on the palm tree
that it's growing out leaves so
you go up the trunk and at the top of
the trunk that's where the leaves come
out and there are new leaves
made and there's new pieces of trunk
made other kinds of plants
other kinds of trees for example they'll
make branches and leaves and so on
all the way up the trunk not just at the
top but if you look at a palm tree
and uh you look at the um uh there's
there's just this one place where
there's growth that's the thing which
you can get
um very sort of uh um high nutrient food
heart of palm is the is the uh
well i guess it's called in biology the
apical meristem the actual
piece of tissue that is at the top of
the of the of the palm tree
that is the place where growth occurs
and where you know leaves new leaves are
sprouting out and things like this
okay so one of the issues with the palm
tree you've got this trunk of the palm
tree
and it's going to put one leaf out it's
going to put another leaf out
it's going to put another leaf out
question is what angle do those leaves
come out at
so for example one thing you might
imagine is leaves go up
you know that you've got the the the
plant some
leaf comes out on one side next leaf
might come out on the exact opposite
side
or but now if you imagine the next leaf
then if it's
if if the rule is leaves come out on
exactly the opposite side
alternate leaves come out on exactly
opposite sides you'll get a situation
where
kind of every other leaf is piled up in
the same direction
and that's that's a little weird you
don't see a lot of plants that way
to work that way instead what you see is
the leaves all seem to come out of
different directions
and it turns out that that um the
there's a there's a general rule for
plants that leaves
successive leaves usually come out about
137 degrees apart
so that means as you go up there that
the trunk the leaf comes out
the next leaf if it was pointed in the
exact opposite direction it would be 180
degrees from the previous leaf
but actually it's about 137 degrees away
from the previous leaf
then you go to the next one it's 137
degrees away from that previous leaf
and so on and it turns out that 137
um which is um uh for mathy people it's
the golden ratio
in radians um it's uh
uh um that
angle actually has the interesting
property that it is
actually optimized for sort of
the leaves never pile up the the if you
look
on any particular in any particular sort
of segment you'll
the leaves are sort of evenly spaced
around the plant as they as you go up
um so that's one question is how does
the plant achieve
that well the answer is it's achieved
through
this whole sort of diffusion process um
and what what's happening is every time
a leaf comes
a shoot comes out um i know whether it's
a positive or negative thing but
let's say it's it's some uh
yeah actually probably the best way to
think about it every time
so there's some particular plant hormone
they're called auxins for plants
that is a growth hormone just like we
have human growth hormone
plants have have plant growth hormone uh
called auxin which is a substance that
diffuses through the plant
that sort of signals that the parts of
the plant that can grow
to to actually grow so you have this
uh this substance that's telling the
blood saying you know okay you can you
can grow
and then what happens is if you look
kind of around a ring at the top of the
plant that's in the palm tree
you'll you'll see that there's uh you
know let's say there's a there's an
increasing concentration of this this
hormone but
at the beginning it's evenly spread
around the um uh
around this ring okay so then a leaf
comes out
and that uses up a certain amount of
that substance so it depletes the amount
of substance that's on that at that
and that angle on this ring okay so then
then the next thing that comes out
should be at the place where
there is the most of this stuff still
left so that would be at the beginning
that would just be on the opposite side
but if you keep doing this it's sort of
a mathematical fact
that if there's a certain if if at a
particular angle you've depleted
the the the the sort of the growth
growth
hormone then and you you keep doing that
all different angles
turns out it doesn't take very long
before the the average
angle at which you have maximum growth
hormone
relative to where it was on the step
before is the 137 degrees
and that's kind of the mechanics i think
of how plants
managed to to do this make this pattern
of leaves coming out or is it
successfully 137 degrees away
okay why is this relevant to palm trees
so if you have a palm tree
readily available i don't um you can
look at the trunk of the palm tree and
you will see the leaf scars
on the palm on the on the trunk of where
leaves have previously come out
and if you measure the angle so it kind
of goes around in a spiral
around the around the the um uh the
trunk of the
of the palm and you'll find that that
the angle of that spiral
um the uh it's a little bit tricky to do
the
all the sort of angle chasing but you'll
find that the the successive if you look
at two
things which are sort of successively
one above each other
in height on the spiral you should find
that they're 137 degrees apart
in in the going around the trunk
direction so to speak
so actually this phylotaxis scheme that
plants use
this sometimes called fibonacci
phylotaxis
because this golden ratio um
uh number that turns into this 137
degrees
is also the ratio of between successive
fibonacci numbers so the fibonacci
series
is the the you take the nth fibonacci
number
is the n minus first plus the minus
second so it goes 1
1 2 3 5 8 13
21 oh i'd have to work out my next
fibonacci number but
it goes 1 1 1 plus 1 is 2
1 then you go 2 plus 1 is 3 3 plus 2 is
5.
5 plus 3 is eight and so on um and the
ratio
of successive things so that's eight
over five thirteen over eight
twenty one over thirteen and so on that
ratio
of terms in the fibonacci series um as
you as you go on with that series
that ratio uh becomes approximately
1.618
um which is the golden ratio otherwise
known as square root of five plus one
over two
and that that ratio is also the thing
that governs this angle
that shows up in in plant growth okay
where else does it show up
all over the place plants are very
unoriginal they use this
everywhere so uh not only palm trees but
also if you look at pine cone
the the if you look for example at the
bottom of pine cone you'll see that same
angle
showing up as the way that different
parts of the pine cone form
you look at a strawberry you'll find the
same thing for the little
little um seed dots on the strawberry
look at a raspberry
same story look at um uh different kinds
of petals on a
on a flower same story look at
um uh many kinds of plants which have a
sort of stalk
and then they produce leaves out from
the stalk same story
occasionally a plant will have a
different scheme occasionally it will do
ultimate sides but that's pretty rare um
the uh so so this kind of this is a this
is a place where sort of
it's actually a very good example of
sort of mathematics people get
quite confused actually about this um
about the exact way that the fibonacci
series relates to what's going on
because
it's not really the fibonacci series
it's it's it's a it's a thing that
has some of the same origins of the
fibonacci series but it's not really
directly the fibonacci series
it comes about because of this this
process of
of uh when there is this when there's
growth it produces
it sort of depletes things at one angle
and then
as a result of sort of you can solve the
equations if you want to
and um you can kind of see that the the
optimal case will be this
this um this golden ratio case but it
doesn't really quite have the same
precise origin as that adding up of
numbers thing that you get in the
fibonacci case and it's also very
confusing
because um when you look at the palm
tree case
where you have this 137 degree angle you
can plainly see from the successive
leaves coming out
and then you compare that to what
happens on a raspberry for example
it's a little bit tricky to do the sort
of geometric transformation between
this straight stalk versus this thing
where it's putting out little pieces of
the
of the raspberry and so on it's it's
surprisingly tricky actually to do that
there's a there's a nice picture of it
in my new kind of science book actually
where i tried to unscramble how you how
you get those transformations to work
but um it's a very uh by the way the the
thing if you look in the center of a
daisy for example
the the little um uh stamens is that
what they're called the
the um the little yellow things oh gosh
um uh that um uh
that are where the you know the bees go
to get um
uh pollen and so on the the um those are
arranged also
in this in a phylotaxis spiral and they
also have this kind of golden ratio
uh angle that shows up
let's see um
oh boy david brown is suggesting a cool
looking animal for a kind of
a kind of crab yeah it does look cool um
okay ah
my gosh okay all right
we got um
um oh a lot of questions here all right
i'm going to take a completely different
um um let's see
um it's a question here
okay it's a question from waft lord do
you think life forms have a baseline
program
that is informed and coded by the
environment and experiences
is that baseline program evolving over
generations or is it hardwired
okay it's interesting question we've
been talking about biology here
um you know many organisms
uh they don't really that there's a
question
of of can an organism learn at all
and then can it pass its learning on to
future generations
so there are some things in particularly
lower organisms and some things in us
they're just completely hardwired um
there are there are even things that
involve
nerve cells there are reflex arcs in our
spinal cord there are
there are things in in organisms where
they just
it's a it's a reflex you you know you
touch something hot you pull away
i don't think that's that's a thing
that's not learnt in successive
generations
it's a kind of built-in feature of the
way that our
uh our nervous system is constructed but
yet there are other things
where we can learn you know
like if you're a bird or something you
know you
apparently have to well some things sort
of come naturally but some things you
have to kind of learn
about how to fly and so on um
there are pieces that sort of come
naturally and there are pieces that you
have to learn in successive generations
what good does it do evolution to have
things where you have to learn on
successive
generations well the main thing is if
you
know that um if if you are
wired to eat this particular kind of
thing
and you're just wired that way and
there's nothing else you can eat
well then maybe that food supply dries
up for some reason
well then you as a as a as a species
are you know your kind of toast because
you you you know you're wired to eat
that particular thing and sorry that
particular thing isn't available so
you're just going to die out
but if on the other hand you learn what
you're supposed to eat
and every successive generation learns
what it's supposed to eat
then even if that particular piece of
food supply
disappears you'll learn something else
that you can eat
and and so this idea that it's it's more
flexible it's
it's if if everything is kind of burnt
in it's very fragile if you've got it
wrong
then you're completely toast if you um
uh but if you can learn in every
successive generation
then things could be a little different
and you can learn to deal with them
and so that's sort of an evolutionary uh
feature of learning now there's a big
question
which is to what extent the traits of
organisms
are uh are determined genetically and to
what extent they're things where in the
life of the organism
something happens and then it passes
that to its to its to its children
so there used to be back in in uh a
century ago or more there used to be
sort of the darwinian theory of
evolution
which kind of said it's all natural
selection and it and
and the traits that survive are the
traits are just determined by
your you're given you know the role of
the dice gives you certain genetics
that will determine and the ones that
are successful in the sense that they
have more children
will be the ones that win out et cetera
et cetera et cetera and
the course of your life so to speak and
you know you won't if
if you uh if you're a bird and you
uh spend your time doing flapping
exercises and it makes your wings longer
uh that's all well and good for you but
you're not going to pass that trait to
your children
um the uh so but then there was a
different theory
uh due to a person called lamarck um
lamarchism
which was sort of a a competitor to
darwinism
and it said that during the um
uh you know what happens during the
lifetime of an organism
can be passed to its progeny so if the
organism had had
you know had done lots of flapping of
its wings the wings got longer okay then
it's progeny will have longer wings
that was a different theory one of the
things that was really bad actually that
that um
uh back in um in soviet times this is
now more history than science but but um
uh particularly through a chat called
lysenko there was a there's a whole
push to think about agriculture in the
soviet union in terms of
lamarckianism and it was turned out to
be a wrong scientific theory basically
mostly not completely
and it was and it caused a lot of
trouble to kind of enmesh the kind of
the politics of of uh this scientific
theory versus the other scientific
theory
and uh you know they happened to pick
the wrong one and that led to
a lot of incorrect uh inferences
about sort of the way that you should do
developments of crops and so on
but anyway the the um so the result
partly as a result of that
um uh you know the lamakian theory of
evil
is not relevant to its progeny et cetera
et cetera et cetera
it's like forget it there's nothing
passed down that way
well as is usually the case in biology
things are not quite as simple as that
and and needless to say there are things
that are known
where where there will be effects from
what happens to one organism
on successive ones for example one
that's known as various kinds of vitamin
deficiencies
that are um that will produce things
that
affect the the progeny of one of of uh
uh you know in in during fetal
development or something it affects one
generation and then it can actually be
passed down to successive generations
um because of things that aren't to do
with
the genome although i think there are
some effects actually which are known
that have to do with the regulation of
the genome and um
let's see how does this work i think
there are some things to do with the
various kinds of metadata associated
with the genome
but it's worth realizing when organisms
when you
go from one organism to its progeny it
isn't just
the dna there's also you know an egg
cell or something like that that is
passed down and that contains
additional stuff so you know even if we
had the dinosaur dna for example
we would still need something some
carrier there's some sort of thing like
a
dinosaur egg to to put that in to be
able to uh
uh to actually make a dinosaur and that
that additional sort of metadata that
comes along with
the dna can carry other things which are
much more lamarcian
in the way that they get inherited um so
it's one of these cases where
sort of as a result of kind of partly
the the politics meets
science of what was going on and so on
that you know a theory that that
actually wasn't
i mean it was not the dominant theory
but it wasn't
100 wrong it was only 98 wrong
and um you know the two percent is still
is still interesting
now when it comes to learning uh
much learning that gets done by
organisms is learning that gets done in
a particular generation and never passed
to future generations
um and that seems to be true and one of
the key things that sort of can happen
then
is when it becomes the case that you can
pass learning
from one generation to the next and that
happens in some animals
it also happens dominantly in humans and
and clearly
the main innovation that humans had that
allows that to happen is is language
and the idea that we can uh go and do uh
live streams like this and talk about
things and maybe pass on some
some knowledge that i've accumulated in
my life
uh pass on to to other people who will
then pass it on to other people and so
on
um that that works is a feature
that seems to be largely enabled by
human language
and that's a very important feature and
that's that's sort of a way in which our
species very different from others
or seems to be very different from
others we don't know whether whales and
things like that have a similar
kind of ability to pass information in
sort of symbolic language
um not clear um but uh
you know it's something that's a very
important feature for humans um and it's
something that
that um uh certainly affects the the
it's sort of a dominant effect
in the evolution of of um uh and what
happens in in sort of human
evolution um i mean and people then uh
talk about the
the idea of sort of memes that are kind
of the the
the thoughts analog of genes that is you
know if there's an idea
that gets passed from me to the next
generation to the next generation and so
on
that idea can have the same kind of uh
sort of natural selection phenomena go
on with it
um that as as for example
an idea where the idea is never tell
anybody this idea
is probably going to go extinct because
after all
if people follow that idea they never
tell the idea to anybody and so the idea
isn't going to be known to anybody else
and if it's an idea which is very
popular and the idea sort of spawns more
copies of itself
then it's going to be carried forward
and it's going to as
as people say in the in sort of social
media world you know go
viral so to speak and uh and replicate a
lot i think that that
that phraseology i haven't heard that
being as a result of the pandemic that
we're still in
i haven't heard the the uh too many
people attacking the
the um that phraseology but maybe it
will will yet come
um let's see
uh um
yeah okay there's a comment from mark
here about epigenetics of a few
if you don't chew on hard food for
hundreds of years your jaws will get
uh will get small your teeth will be
crooked
and you'll have trouble breathing at
night it's interesting i i think that's
a
uh yeah it's a it's a um uh
in a sense if you have the idea that
you're only gonna eat this kind of food
and that gets passed down
as an idea you can certainly have you
know
okay fair enough that there's a if you
learn in in the
in your in your kind of um
uh in your generation you learn
something and
that has some uh
know that that has an effect that um as
a result of your learning you do or
don't survive
based on some physical trait that you
have um
then then it's it's um then that's
something that can
again enmesh with this whole sort of
standard process of natural selection
it's always interesting this process of
thinking
thinking in terms of natural selection
so to speak is always kind of
interesting
and it's interesting in in um in
different fields
there are always this sort of thinking
in terms of some particular um sort of
dominant
way of thought i mean like for example
in economics
there's very different ways of thinking
that uh you know
because the consumers do this and then
that happens and then that happens
in medicine there are definite ways of
thinking in physics there are definite
ways of thinking each of these fields
has a sort of definite way of thinking
that sometimes takes a while to learn
and get and get used to and sometimes
they're a more natural fit for somebody
than another
um okay let's see maybe another couple
of things here
um
okay there's a question another biology
question
about butterflies and their four-stage
life cycle where in the last stages of
reproducing i don't know
i i strongly suspect that a lot of these
things like like it really does seem
very wacky when you have a
you know a whole caterpillar and then it
makes a chrysalis
and then it comes out as a butterfly
it's like that's a really kludgy way to
do things why do you have to do it that
way
well it's and maybe the answer is
a large part of that clue genus has to
do with
the fact that as you go through
evolution
you typically only make a small change
at each generation
if you make a dramatic change you say
i'm not going to be a butterfly
i'm going to be a a thing that um is you
know
has something completely different
characteristic the chances are you're
not going to be able to correctly
get to that totally different thing in
one generation you're just going to die
out
so so typically you only make small
moves in evolution
and the fact that you're only making
small moves at every successive
generation
means that if you got one scheme which
was be a caterpillar or something
you don't get to say oh forget that
scratch that idea completely
let's just have it be a butterfly from
the beginning you don't get to do that
you only get to make these
small moves because otherwise you don't
you know you you kind of die or
die out in in the process of trying to
make that larger move and it's a
it's a feature of biological evolution i
don't think we yet understand that well
actually have some recent ideas about
how this might work um don't understand
that well the real effect
of sort of this incrementalism in in
biological evolution and what its sort
of overall meta effect is
i mean it's always a interesting thing
again it's like how do things grow
sort of what's the planning for how do
you get to a butterfly
it kind of reminds me of what's the
planning for how do you land a
spacecraft on the moon
you know it's not self-evident that you
have two different pieces of the
spacecraft and they
kind of go into earth orbit and then
they dock and then one piece goes off
this way and another piece goes off that
way and so on
um each one of these things is kind of a
scheme for achieving a result
and the caterpillar butterfly is some
scheme for achieving the result that
seems kind of clutchy to to one on the
face of it
but um and no doubt when you kind of
think natural selection wise
there'll be a whole story about how the
caterpillar has certain access to food
sources
and then this happens and that happens
and you'll be able to certainly tell a
back story
about why it had to be that way it's not
clear that that is
really the reason it could be that it's
just well there were caterpillars
and you know then there was an evolution
of this and it was all sort of small
small changes and so on
um okay
oh there's questions here about how do
bean plants find their
poles to climb up wait a minute i
thought you put a pole
in the ground and you put the bean plant
near the pole but but there's the
question of how does it
how does it sort of uh um
how does it know i i don't know the
answer to that
um i would think uh so so plants
have um uh
they have some ability so some plants
like like insect eating plants
you know they they actually can move um
i think plants in general
well when plants for example turn
towards the sun
um that's a
i think what happens is there is little
fibers
inside the plant they're really kind of
like the plants analog of mussels that
we have
and i think they have to do with the
actual the moving of a plant like
turning a sunflower head towards the sun
now i you know what is the control
system inside the sunflower that does
that i don't completely know that
um the uh i mean it is interesting that
it is possible to have a plant that
seems like a very
static thing be able to respond to its
environment
i think people people say you know it's
like
you always kind of think somehow for
some reason it's a very british thing to
talk to your plants
it's a it's one thing to talk to your
pets it's quite another thing to talk to
your plants but but some people do it
um and maybe it's more of a benefit to
the person than to the plant
but or you know playing music to your
plants to get them to grow in a certain
way
is that even vaguely plausible or is
that just totally nuts
well uh you know it does seem to be the
case that plants
can uh can they they do have some
ability
to to take sensory input as the
sunflower turning itself to the sun
indicates um exactly how that sensory
ability works is
is not i think well well understood i
think it's also the case you know one
thing
that is in the kind of um the alien
intelligence type category
you know maybe plants are sort of you
know have a
have sort of a you know a network of of
uh
of of um chemical processes or filaments
or whatever else
that is doing something a little bit
like what brains do but maybe it's doing
it
a thousand ten thousand times slower
would we know not clear
um you know these are these are
interesting possibilities
and um there's certainly you know people
will make
um um and when you look at like the
the root system of a plant you know
there's a question of of to what extent
it can
um uh um uh
the what what kind of information
content can be distributed that way you
know there's this
in this avatar movie there's a whole
planet covered with plants that
communicate
i think through their root system um and
that's the you know the plants are
intelligent
well we can go into a long discussion
about the meaning of
intelligence and uh the difficulty of
really distinguishing between
that which is intelligent and that which
is merely computational
and i don't think plants i don't think
it's an obvious obvious dividing line
but um yeah interesting interesting um
uh questions about sort of how plants
think so to speak um
well let's see um there's a question
here from
easton how would you recommend
developing a work ethic to get into
science and technology
um for somebody who is is uh younger and
i'm being reminded that i'm running out
of time here but uh
um the um
well you know the thing about i i i
would say that my comment about sort of
work ethics and so on is do stuff you're
interested in
if you're not interested it's you know
then yes you can kind of
force yourself to do it but somehow it
doesn't work that well
at least for most people it's like kind
of you know you're doing some class
you're really interested in this class
you're going to remember what happened
in this class if it's a class where it's
like well i got to do this and you know
yeah i got to do the homework instead
take me an
hour and it just sort of rushed through
it and it's like oh i don't really know
what i'm doing i'm kind of
sleepwalking through it you won't
remember it and it's almost like what
was the point of taking it it's kind of
like
it's kind of like um uh you know to some
extent it's like well i
vaguely you know then years later it's
like well yeah i
vaguely remember i saw some example of
that back in this class but i don't
really remember it and i wasn't really
paying attention in this class
one of the things that drives me most
most crazy sometimes is
is um you know i'll be talking to some
younger person about some topic and
they'll say oh yeah i did a class about
that
you know last year it's like okay and
you start talking about the content say
i don't remember anything about that
that was last year i did that class
that's a really bad sign i mean i have
to say that the things that i've learned
i
you know i've mostly learned them when
i'm interested in them and i typically
remember them
you know i'm for better or worse i have
a pretty good memory
which possibly is because i mostly learn
things i'm interested in
or possibly it's just because i happen
to intrinsically have a good memory i
don't really know
i suppose i should be able to detect
that by by looking at my children
who uh also have rather good memories
but but
um i'm not sure that's again one of
these complicated questions of is that
some genetic trait of having a good
memory or is that because
they've also adopted the point of view
of only learning things that they're
interested in so uh
it's it's hard to disentangle those
kinds of things but i think that that's
a
an important thing is is to fight figure
out what you're interested now sometimes
they're things where
you don't know you're interested you
have to get over a little bit of a hump
to know you're interested you know it's
it's like well there's a class on this
and and well maybe it sounds vaguely
interesting i don't know
or it's a required thing it's like oh
gosh i don't think it'll be interesting
well if it turns out actually the whole
thing or at least some part of it you
find oh this is really interesting
then you're kind of on on on track there
and i think that's some
so you know by the time you're sort of
forcing yourself to do things it's not a
good sign
i think it's like then pick something
where you really want to do it where
where the thing is pulling you into
doing it
rather than something where you find you
have to push yourself to
to do it and you know having said that
i've worked in my life on a lot of very
large projects
and um you know it isn't the case that
every single day every single moment
every single piece of what you're doing
is like totally i want to be doing this
particular piece right now i mean i was
working
just yesterday on something i'm writing
about um about multi-way touring
machines we can have a long discussion
about that
it sounds like a very technical topic it
actually has very interesting
implications for
theory of consciousness which um uh you
might think was
not connected but it turns out it's a
really interesting way to help one
understand
how quantum mechanics and consciousness
bunch of other things work but anyway
at the that's all kind of fun
but when you're in the weeds of the
multi-way turing machines and trying to
figure out
why this particular result of this
computer particular computer experiment
comes out this way
and why it doesn't come out that way
those things well
they're not the most exciting things but
it's kind of like
the the pull from this project
of i really want to understand how this
works because it's going to help me
understand how things like consciousness
work
um that's enough of a pull that the fact
there's this little bump that i have to
get over of understanding this kind of
uh crazy thing with with some
causal and variance property of some
turing machine that
um uh that it's okay i get over that
bump because the pull is large enough
uh for from what i'm what i'm trying to
get to i think that
um you know it's also perhaps
uh uh sometimes you do have to get into
a certain rhythm
of you know how you get started on
project what happens if you had to
i mean i think one of the things i've
noticed with with young people
is um one of the things that i think is
almost a paradox of the modern world
is i think high school students are
busier than anybody else at least in
in sort of the the the most upscale high
school students are
busier than sort of almost anybody else
and
i'm not sure if that's a good thing i
personally don't think it's a
particularly good thing i think that
that's how you end up sort of
sleepwalking through a bunch of things
and i think it would be better
if one was a little less busy and one
was able to like oh yeah you know i can
think about that
um you know i'm really interested in
that and you go spend more time on that
rather than
you are programmed to spend this number
of hours on this every week
and i think that um the thing that um
that had um um uh
the this question of if you if you do
have your time sliced up and
and for example for me because you know
i have a day job of
running a tech company and i do weird
things like these kinds of live streams
and so on
and these are all scheduled in various
ways and uh you know i have a pretty
scheduled life actually
mostly and that means that i sort of
have these blocks of time where i can do
creative work
and it has taken me quite a while
actually
to get to the point where when i say
okay i've got a two hour block to do
this thing
great um and then like within a minute
be able to actually be doing something
productive
rather than like oh what's going on here
let me think about what's happening let
me
kind of come to equilibrium before i can
sort of pounce and start to
start doing things that's something that
has i've sort of
over the years i've kind of learned
better how to kind of switch
and be okay now i'm doing this let me
get into action on doing that
and i'm not sure that i have a i mean i
have for myself various schemes for
doing that i
like one thing i mean this is a thing
about just doing projects is that
well one thing is always leave good
notes for yourself that is i'm always
making these these notebooks or notebook
um things in in sort of open language
code and so on and i'm always writing
stuff in there and i i'm like
even though right now i remember exactly
what's going on
i know that within a week where i i kind
of measured this a bit my
my my sort of human memory time is about
three days i can remember
pretty much all the details um and that
that's okay but if it's longer than that
if i didn't leave notes for myself i'm
uh you know i'm not going to remember
what i was doing
and there's sort of a point where if you
leave kind of a
a piece of sort of uh sometimes when i'm
when doing things you get into this kind
of state
where you really understand what's going
on you've got all these different pieces
and you're
able to knit them all together if you
can't finish while you're in that state
things all fall apart when you come back
later it's like oh well i remember i was
in that state where i was figuring
everything out
and i got to come back to that and it's
very sort of
it's very demotivating that you're
thinking about those kinds of things
that you have to say i have to pull
these pieces back together
before i can start to work again anyway
a few thoughts about some
uh kind of
work ethics i mean i i would say that
that um another
general principle of sort of work ethic
type stuff
is um uh you know
the more you learn the more you'll know
and the more you'll be able to learn
more stuff and you know what i've always
noticed is
the more things i know about different
kinds of areas and all that kind of
thing
it all kind of fits together in some
sense and it really helps you
to learn you know if you say well i just
want to learn this one particular area
you will be much less effective than if
you've learnt broadly
across a bunch of areas because it just
is a bunch of sort of analogies that you
can make
a bunch of ways of understanding things
that sort of jump from one area to
another
about a bunch of ways of thinking that
you learn from one area that you can
then apply in other areas and so on
i mean i happen to be just in the midst
of a really grand unification of a bunch
of areas of
of science that i'm really quite excited
about that um
if it all works out we'll we'll deeply
leverage the fact that i've learned
about physics and mathematics and
and computation and a bit about things
like biology and economics and so on
if this sort of grand unification works
out then i'll i'll feel very pleased
with myself that i actually
know enough about these different areas
to be able to see these common threads
and so on
um but uh uh don't i can't i can't
report success on that yet
but um but in general i would say that
you know learning lots of different
things is really worthwhile
even if you think but but locally learn
things you're interested in
rather than just doing the sort of wrote
well i should learn this and this and
this and i mean for myself
i've most of the time when i learn stuff
i have a particular goal
some particular project i'm doing and
then i'm going to backtrack and figure
out
if i'm trying to get to this goal i need
to learn this i need to learn that i
need to learn that
and sometimes the actual process of
learning things
is some i mean you know every time i
learn
some some area that has its own sort of
conceptual structure
it's like oh my gosh i don't understand
anything about this area
but i kind of know a certain amount
about how to learn things in general
i mean i've been learning some areas of
pure mathematics recently
that i've never understood before i've
been um
oh things to do with type theory and a
bunch of other things where i've sort of
had some vague understanding but i've
never really
dug deep in these areas and i now
realize that i have to understand these
areas and the first few iterations of
trying to understand this it's actually
pretty hard work and it's pretty much
i'm not understanding this i don't
understand i don't get it people are
telling me a new thing
and it's like oh i don't understand that
it doesn't really fit in with anything i
know and
and then there's this very satisfying
feeling at some point as you've
chipped away at it enough finally for me
at least it's like
it's really fun you know it's like it
all happens at once you
you get it you kind of wrap your arms
around the area
and then then it starts to be the case
that you know things people tell you
it's like oh yeah okay i understand that
it fits in here and here and here
um but it's sometimes in that process of
getting to the point where you really
understand it it's a you know that's a
that's a hard
uphill battle so to speak um to to get
to that point and i think that
in the process of doing that the um the
best thing
that helps me always is um
that at each point you say well what's a
simple thing i can answer based on what
i know what's a really simple example of
this
rather than like oh yeah well and you
know it's a very complicated thing and
that's where i'm trying to get to
it's like what's a simple thing that i
can actually work out where i can even
though i'm not getting my arms around
the whole thing
where i can get this little piece and i
can really understand that little piece
because one of the things that helps
you know i guess i'm a person who uh
likes to understand things pretty
pretty thoroughly when i when i think i
understand them
i mean i i'm very bad i i know people
who can kind of jump to new ideas
without really understanding the
previous ideas in the chain
and and not kind of just crash and burn
at the end of it
i'm not particularly good at that i i
find it much better to solidly
understand one thing then build the next
thing then build the next thing i
suppose
the level of sort of analogies can kind
of do this jumping thing
but at the level of actually trying to
trying to work things out and you know
i'm always and there's another thing i
would say about
you know another thing to say about sort
of getting work done
i always like to concretify the things
i'm doing i like to
write a piece of language code that does
it see the picture come out
did i understand well if the picture
came out the way i thought the picture
should come out then yes i understand
something rather than just
i have a conceptual idea about what's
going on is turn it into computational
language
and see that i really really understand
it and that's that's a super helpful
thing for me and it's a way of kind of
structuring
the the sort of things i think about i
mean i i happen to be a person
who's really very bad at just abstractly
close my eyes and think about stuff
i mean i kind of have to be interacting
with a computer or something like that
to sort of concretify the things i'm
thinking about i think other people work
a little differently in that regard
but that's another thing that really
helps in terms of of like did i do
anything this hour
well yes i did i look i produced this
whole notebook i've done all these
things i've got all these pictures
i made something rather than just like
well i sat and thought for an hour and i
don't remember anything i thought about
so so these things where you can sort of
get some concrete progress but as
as you're trying to climb the hill of
some area that you don't understand
sort of picking off these things that
are simple and
where you can make it concrete and write
a piece of computational language and do
it
and see that yes you know according to
type theory this and this and this
happens okay let me do a simple example
let me write a piece of computational
language that just does that
by the way you know in my experience
doing those kinds of things
you by being explicit like that
you can often you often end up with a
much better understanding than sort of
almost anybody else has
by being able to to actually ground it
in something where you can actually
do it rather than just talk about it so
to speak
anyway my two cents worth about that
all right i think i have to go
unfortunately because my
my day job um uh
um calls all right just
one question here we're back to biology
why don't trees and plants resonate and
break in high winds like tall buildings
or towers
um i think they do
i mean i you know i have a live in a
place where there are lots of trees on
on where i live and it's really quite
common that
you know when they're very high winds
trees will you know branches will fall
off trees will break et cetera et cetera
et cetera
i think the principal thing that
determines whether whether you'll have
catastrophic failure
in the case of things like high winds is
is the thing
uh very is the thing flexible
you know can it bend if there's a high
wind if it bends in a direction
that's fine and then maybe it bends back
when the gust is over or whatever
that's okay the thing that's really bad
is it's very very strong but it's very
brittle
and as soon as it it it is bent at all
it's like snap the whole thing breaks
and so with buildings for example some
building materials
like wood for example is not brittle
kind of plant
you know the the plants had this idea
first so to speak
it you know it it bends um uh whereas um
and same with steel and so on as well
but whereas things that are made from
stone
let's say stone doesn't bend stone if
you
you know if you take a stone pillar and
you twist it somewhat
you know you you you try and you try and
deform it it's not going to just
bend and then bend back instead if you
if you
uh if you if you uh sort of
if you uh try and deform it it will just
break
and actually well another time we can
talk about crack formation
and why that happens and why some
materials are ductile
and can just deform and other materials
are brittle and
as soon as you you um sort of
displace them they'll just break all
right i think i have to wrap up here but
there were um
a lot of really good questions here so i
look forward to next week
um being able to go through more of
these
thanks very much and bye for now